just let the speakers in chairman thank
you
and your live chat hello margaret
hello we're having a few technical
glitches at start here but forgive us
for that um so good evening everybody
and welcome
we are live are we adam we are yes
marvelous uh good evening everybody and
welcome to tonight's virtual
meeting of stratfor naval district
council's planning committee
my name is counselor peter richards and
i will be your chairman for this evening
a few housekeeping notes if i may to
start us off with uh please note that
this meeting is being live streamed and
recorded
for publication on both the council's
website and on youtube
members you will all have been provided
with accounts of etiquette virtual
meetings in advance of tonight's meeting
but to reiterate a few of these salient
points
please can you make sure that your
device is either fully charged or is
charging
please remember to mute your microphones
when you are not speaking of course
remember to unmute them when you are
speaking
if you could please indicate in the chat
bar when you wish to speak
i would be most grateful and i will call
you to speak at an appropriate time
um if for any reason you encounter any
i.t problems causing you to drop
out of the virtual meeting please make
every effort to get back in as soon as
you can
if you're unable to rejoin the meeting
and we will continue with business
provider we are still
correct um and you can then rejoin us
for uh
for anything after that um
i can confirm that checks have been made
in presence
of our legal officer that all members of
the committee are in attendance and they
have confirmed that they can see in here
and that they have read all of the uh
relevant documentation
uh let me introduce now our officers who
are online with us
um first of all from community services
we have ann banks
our legal officer is ross chambers and
our planning
officers in no particular order are
charlotte dicks amy flute and joe brooks
with alice cosnet as our planning
manager alex i believe you have a
statement you'd like to make
thank you chairman my role is to provide
impartial advice and to assist members
in their decision taking
thank you thank you very much and for
members of the public that have
registered to speak it will only be
people that have registered to speak
that we will call to speak um when you
are called to speak if you could please
press start and six on your telephone
keypads that will unmute your microphone
we will check that you can hear us and
we can hear you
and then i will ask you to begin your uh
your speech
um please if you could also turn off any
live streams or any background streams
that you may have going it does cause a
significant amount
of feedback to us um and it is slightly
delayed as well so if you can
please follow on your phones on the item
that you're speaking on i'd be most
grateful okay um
let's move straight into our agenda for
the evening first of all could we have
some apologies please
generally got apologies from councillors
curtis and henshaw seraphin
marvelous thank you any disclosures of
interest
lots of shaking heads counselor parry
please
thank you good evening chair i just
wanted to highlight i
have from time to time been an
occasional
made the occasional purchase at pragnals
in
wood street um but as far as i'm
concerned i don't believe that would
have any bearing
on the application that's in front of me
this evening
okay no problem thank you mr parry
councillor adam next please
um just to disclose that in relation to
item number three
um i believe some years ago um in my
capacity as a structural engineer i did
do a bit of work
on this site um for the foundations of
the sort of ferris wheel um i believe
this was before i was a councillor
um i didn't have any interaction with
the applicant and i
um i don't believe this compromises my
position on the committee and i'd say i
come here with an open mind um
and i'm happy to proceed on my basis
okay marvellous understood thank you
very much
okay i'm just checking to see if we have
any more and forgive me i've just been
alerted the fact that my internet
connection is not great so i apologize
if you
you're hearing intermittent words and
and we get caught up but hopefully we
should be okay
um all right uh let's move on to our
next item which is the minute so you're
all happy that the minutes reflect
the last meeting and i can sign those
when we're next in the office if i could
have a thumbs up from everyone that
would be ideal
fabulous that is everyone brilliant that
is everyone
okay let's move into our first
application for the evening which is
application reference twenty zero zero
four five six ful that is recreation
ground
uh car pocket swan's nest lane our
presenting officer is charlotte dix
charlotte
over to you thank you very much chairman
let me just share my presentation with
you
you can see the title side there um
so the site is indicated on the map by
the black circle
the application site forms part of the
recreation ground in stratford-upon-avon
close to the river raven
this slide shows the application site
edged in red in the center of the slide
the site is within the
stratford-upon-avon conservation area
the edge of which is indicated by the
pink line
the red buildings represent listed
buildings so you can see the rst
over the river at the tramway bridge
here
and swan's nest hotel to the east
so this is an application for full
planning permission for the installation
and operation of the observation wheel
and associated apparatus
for a period of up to six months out of
every calendar year for a temporary
period
over the next five years this slide
shows the proposed elevation of the
wheel
the plan shows that the wheel would
measure 40 meters in total height
this plan shows the proposed block plan
indicating where the ticket office would
be cited
along with the welfare facilities and
the wheel itself
this aerial view demonstrates again the
sighting of the wheel in relation to
the boat club to the north the swans
nest hotel
to the east and the public house
to the southwest along with the open
ground here
so this photo shows a view of the site
from the tramway pathway to the south
east of the site the photo shows the
entrance to the public car park
when you approach from swan's nest lane
with the site being
in the area of car park centrally here
you can see the the tower of the rst in
the background
this photo is taken from close to where
the boats club is located
facing south towards the site the area
of car park visible here
and then the area on this side of the
posts would be where the
wheel is sighted
so this photo is taken from the open
grassland immediately to the west of the
site
you can see the boat clipper on the
left-hand side of the photo with swan's
nests
centrally and the public house on the
right-hand side
again the site is visible here
essentially in the photo
this photo is taken from across the
river
to the north of the sites uh fairly
close to where cox's yard is sited
the tramway bridge is located on the
left-hand side of the photo
and the boat club again visible here the
wheel would be sighted beyond the the
boat club
so this photo is actually taken from the
planning statement
and shows a very similar location to the
previous photo
um just illustrating what the wheel
looked like in situ
and then this photo is taken again from
the planning statement and shows the
wheel as viewed from the car park to the
looking north uh east again the public
house is visible on the left-hand side
of the photo
so just to clarify there are
consultation updates within the update
sheet
uh office recommendation is to grant the
application for a
five-year temporary consent subject to
no new
material considerations being received
before the by
the consultation period and subject to
the suggested conditions and notes which
can be found on pages 10
and 11 of the agenda thank you very much
chairman
marvel scholar thank you very much for
that okay let's move straight to our
speakers our first speaker's tonight is
miss margaret cund
margaret are you there can you hear me
you may need to press star and six to
unmute yourself
just to reiterate star and six on your
keypad will unmute you
can i speak no ah good evening
welcome is that ms kund yes it is
marvelous we didn't hear you start with
but we've got you now so you have three
minutes whenever you're ready to
do feel free to start out we'll give you
a 30 second warning towards the end
thank you i am speaking on behalf of the
stratford society
mr cyril dennis and others if granted
this application would breach
policies to which the council has
undertaken to adhere
under the local neighborhood plan policy
clw.3
endorsed by voters in 2018 developments
on designated local green
space including the recreation ground
which would harm its openness or special
character would not
be permitted the car park falls within
the ambit of that plan
the planning officer's report
acknowledges that the observation wheel
and its associated paraphernalia
would result in some harm to the open
nature of the recreation ground
and the character of the area of
restraint as designated by the council
in its core strategy
twenty eleven thirty one furthermore the
site is in close proximity to a number
of listed buildings
and is within the conservation area in
the words of the report
the wheel does not relate to local
historic features
and local distinctiveness when earlier
this month the council published revised
plans for a riverside corridor
no mention was made of the possibility
of an observation wheel along the site
instead the character is described as
creating a new
outdoor green space which will be a
positive attraction
to draw visitors back to the town
since there have already been two
temporary permissions for the wheel
the recommendation for a further
so-called temporary period of up to five
years
is surprising in using the consequences
of covet 19 as justification
the report overlooks the general view
that staycations will be popular this
year
stratford can expect to be a beneficiary
of this with visitors coming to the town
for its historic character
green open spaces and riverside aspect
rather than being a further attraction a
40 meter high wheel
visible well above the tree line and in
the position
for the very months which see the most
tourists
would be an eyesore
in short while recommending that this
application be granted
the planning office's report does in
fact set out the very grounds on which
it should be rejected
it is unsurprising therefore that the
council should have received only one
letter of support
against 55 letters of objection
including from neighbours concerned
about the level of noise and loss of
privacy
30 seconds in conclusion the
installation of the wheel by the end of
march this year
was obviously at some cost for the
operators coming some four weeks before
today's planning committee meeting
the applicant must have been confident
that installation for six months a year
would be approved
it would be interesting to know how this
could happen
thank you mr thank you very much for
that as just
within your three minutes so very good
um excuse me if you bear with us while i
see if any members have any questions
for you members could you indicate
in the chat for me please if you have
any questions for our speaker
i'll just give that a couple of seconds
i'm not seeing a huge amount of action
in front of people
no okay it looks like there's no
question so i'm just going to thank you
very much for that
um you're probably best place to
continue to watch the live stream
rather than onto your phone so but thank
you for your um your input this evening
all right thank you very much goodbye
bye
okay let's move to our next speaker who
is
miss emily dante uh miss tanter are you
there
you may also need to press star on six
to emit your keypad please start and six
hello there can you hear me we can you
sound quite a long way away uh but we
can hear you
um so you have three minutes as well i
will give you 30 second warning
otherwise whenever you're ready please
do feel free to start
good evening mr chairman and respected
councillors
i want to speak to you tonight about
some of the misconceptions regarding the
panel application
we have submitted we have been operating
on this site for four years now
without any serious complaints on
applying for a formal planning
application
there have been numerous objections
tonight i would like to talk through
these and explain why this
application should be allowed we've
always been a temporary event
only lasting six months at a time
the application under consideration
keeps exactly to those terms of
operation
marking the end of winter and the
beginning of spring
we have been proud to bring fun and
happiness to stratford-upon-avon
pleasing our guests as they have the
opportunity to view the town and
surrounding countryside from march until
september
the stratford-up unhaven observation
wheel remains a popular attraction for
both
residents and visitors alike our
feedback
has always been very positive with many
local residents and guests
from out of town extending on multiple
occasions
local families are proud to invite their
extended family and friends to
experience
this unique attraction during the kobe
crisis we have gone above and beyond the
guidance issued
by the department of media culture and
sport to ensure everyone
enjoys a safe and healthy experience
seeing the observation wheel being
assembled for many people
marks the beginning of a fantastic new
season beyond the colds of winter
the views from the observation wheel are
simply stunning
so much so we've secured a prime
television national programme
to be filmed showing the pure beauty of
the town and the surrounding areas
from a vista which cannot otherwise be
seen
our objective has always been to support
local businesses
and to drive the local economy our
promotional and marketing strategy
has always been to drive the footfall to
all businesses
i go back to my opening statement our
objectives
always have been to operate for only six
months per year
this is the same observation wheel as
previous four years
and all operations are to remain the
same
any noise during construction or d-rig
will be of general and minimum
construction sound
once fully built and operational if you
stand directly next to the observation
wheel
you can hold a conversation at normal
level without interference
this has a structural like appeal a
sculpture-like appeal even
we even enjoyed the honour of being
awarded first place
in stratford-upon-avon in bloom in 2020
for faux flowers
30 seconds heights of abram
a new building residential development
including
also included the wheel as part of their
sales and marketing material
when we first opened four years ago i
made absolutely certain
i distributed my contact information
also engaged with local residents and
businesses to assure that any issues
could be addressed by me personally and
immediately
no issues were raised we hopefully made
part of the town's business and tourism
community assisting with a
covered recovery plan mr chairman
councillors i thank you for your
retirement
for your time and remain at your
disposal
fabulous mr anthony thank you very much
again well within the three minutes um
members do you have any questions for ms
dante please you could indicate in the
chat if you do
counsel adam first please thanks
um it was so hopefully just a quick one
uh it wasn't just
relation to the the wheel that this
application refers to is there any
difference to this
wheel uh compared to the one that's been
on the site for the previous four years
that you mentioned
uh no it is the same wheel okay and um
so just a
follow-up from that in terms of the sort
of usage of it
um how have you found it and obviously
you've mentioned that it was pretty well
used um
is it fairly consistent across the six
months
it is fairly consistent you will have
peaks at holiday times and in warm
weather but it's fairly consistent
thanks very much thank you
okay i'm i'm not seeing any more
uh questions being put in the chats oh i
do apologize cancer cramp has just come
in cancer crime
thank you mr chairman uh just very
briefly it was interesting to hear that
it's gonna be
the same uh wheel as it's been used
before i just wondered what um
how many complaints that um the
the people who were running it had about
noise
um or any issues with it with the wheel
um
hello um hello hello yes
there's been no issues as i said i
personally gave my um
number if there was any issues to allay
any fears
that they could contact us immediately
or um
and nothing was raised with us brilliant
so um yeah you felt it's been
run successfully uh and you you've got
no reason to see why
it should be any different uh in the
future
yes that's correct thank you cheers
thank you bye
thank you marvelous thank you very much
so counselors
last call for any questions i'm going to
give you 10 seconds now to put anything
in the media chat if you have a question
um otherwise we will move on
and given i'm seeing very little
movement and nothing in the chat i
should assume that that is no so
um thank you very much for your
contribution this evening again you'll
probably best place to continue to watch
the live stream
uh on one of your devices so you can you
can hang up your handset now but thank
you again
thank you thanks okay
uh let's now move to our ward member who
is councillor ian frassley councillor
fragile i've seen you once already
hopefully you're still with us
yes i'm still here chair thank you okay
you have five minutes
whenever you're ready do feel free to
start thank you
i am here to represent the residents of
bridgetown who have concerns
particularly those who live on shipston
road from the visual viewpoint
in the current location it is an in
inappropriate 40 meter structure
which can be seen from far wide across
the town
but for the residents of bridgetown its
dominating size is overbearing
obtrusive and impacts on shipstand road
residents privacy
the first wheel we had in stratford
in this location the locals do say that
it was reasonably
noiseless in operation uh with little
noise impact on the local people
but i'm afraid this was not the case for
the following three years after that
um the wheel clunks along with a
continuous noise
on the current wheel now in place
appears to be the same
the observation wheel 2021 report on the
planning portal states that the
approval and installation of previous
wheel over the last three years
provided an opportunity to make a full
assessment of the impact on the time
but it looks like that assessment did
not include noise measurement
and its impact on the locals
there are statements that in the past
the wheels presence
is increased as increased financial
benefit
whilst i accept that this may be true
for the land owner
those who own car parks and hospitality
but to the town
center shops stratfor would be have not
offered any evidence i can find
and i cannot find any evidence elsewhere
the recreation ground is the south of
the river part
of the overall plan for the development
of the riverside project
and as far as i'm aware it is not yet
known or agreed
as to whether or not a wheel and its
positioning would play a part of the
river
riverside project so if the kit
community are mindful to grant this
application
then it should be for three years only
and should also be conditioned to
measure and reduce the noise
levels to much lower than present thank
you chair
that's right thank you very much members
do we have any questions for councillor
actually please
you can indicate in the chat if you do
can see a couple of people typing so i'm
just going to wait until that comes into
the chat
council jennings first please
thank you chairman uh
councillor counselor freshly just one
quick one
do you know of any issues which have
been raised with environmental health on
this
do you know how many complaints there
have been
i i don't know how many official
complaints have been i know
that um obviously uh on the shifts and
road there are lots of complaints
i know it's not a good measure but i
just have a look at social media
and you you'll be filled with bags of
complaints
thank you okay thank you very much
councillor parry next please
[Music]
thank you chair um council jennings
basically has stolen my thunder but i
was specifically of interest
to the ward member that if he's had lots
of
complaints to noise um is there a reason
why
he hasn't raised it with the
environmental health team to carry out a
noise monitor survey
well that's what i'm asking for now
but you you despite all the
uh concerns you've had with the wheel on
the noise you haven't made contact with
the environmental health team to carry
out a noise monitor
monitoring exercise no that's what i'm
thank you for now
okay that's what the residents would
like okay thank you both of you um
for for that um counselor adam next
please
thanks chairman um hi councilman bradley
um it was
just in relation to the type of noise
complaints that you're
that you're seeing are these
specifically in relation to the
operation of the wheel at large um or is
it anything to do with sort of the music
or anything that's going on on the site
look sorry yeah i mean it's the noise of
the wheel itself
and the gondolas that you know can be a
bit clumpy
uh i went down there on sunday i think
it was
and it there was definitely noise coming
from it if you stand
um on the wreck
it goes the other way across the
shipston road
and and did you say sorry i'm wrecked in
saying you said this wasn't as much of
an issue the first year of operation but
it's got worse since exactly
that's what the residents of ships and
roads are telling me
okay thank you very much for that okay
and councillor crump please i don't know
whether you heard
the operator when i was speaking earlier
that left um
the mobile number with with the
residents
um when it was operating previously uh
for various issues including noise
and according to that person they didn't
receive any complaints
um and i've got another issue as another
point as well um
you mentioned social media
the complaints on there are all the
people on social media making complaints
actually
people living nearby or just general
residents of
of the town i'm here representing the
residence of ships and road
and so i'm talking about residents on
ships and road yeah
no about the question about social media
are you are you certain that all those
who have made the points
that if via social media but not via
official
uh measures um are you certain that uh
they
are all people from from that road and
then not
just other parts of the town as well i
know ships and road very well
and the residents know me very well
i don't think you quite answered the
question there councillor
[Music]
i'm going to hold you there for a second
because i don't think we're going to get
very far
whilst i think it's a perfectly valid
question i don't think we're gonna get
the answer that you want
um i'm also a little concerned that
we're relying on uh social media that we
don't have access to right now
um we don't know what's been said there
is a uh clear procedure for making
complaints there was also a clear
procedure for objections to be put into
a planning application
those have all been put through in our
documents here so i think we should
be focusing on the actual evidence not
on what we're
necessarily being told is on social
media um
does any do any other uh counselors have
any questions for counselor actually
before
we move on you could indicate again in
the chat please i'll give you a few
seconds
i'm not seeing a huge amount of movement
so i'm going to say that's a note to
counselor fragi thank you
very much for your input this evening
thank you chair
okay let's move on to uh points of
clarification for officers
again if you could indicate in the chat
please members if you have any questions
for officers that would be appreciated
let's give that a few seconds forgive me
my my computer has been extraordinarily
slow and i can see people typing but
nothing comes up so
here we go councillor mills first please
thanks mr chairman
um um charlotte i can't see her can you
do it
oh yeah um charlotte um just to confirm
it is within the uh conservation area
this
this wheel isn't it and it is an area of
restraint
yes it is within the conservation area
and within the area of restraint as well
that's all i need to know thank you
thank you
councillor parry please thank you chair
um i just wanted to know if if we were
minded to grant this application
if there could be um a strengthened
um condition with regarding
noise that if it reached you know that
but we actually set up if there was a
standard of
noise concern because obviously uh that
does appear to be local residents
concern but i just wonder whether there
could be
uh an appropriate condition whilst we
have
no amplified or live music and that sort
of thing i just wonder whether there is
a
some form of um level that could be put
in from an eh perspective
that would allow us that if if
that if there were lots of complaints of
noise it could then be
you know it could be conditioned to not
exceed a certain level of
of noise whatever that might be i'm not
a noise expert
uh thank you councillor um in terms of
the environmental house comments
um as you've mentioned they have raised
no objections to
the proposal um based on the
fact that the the noise and other
impacts on residential amenity would be
the same as the existing wheel
they have requested the condition in
terms of the no amplified or live music
being played
without any exception um
in terms of um levels of noise and
whether there could be some sort of
restriction or limits
it's not something that we've assessed
as part of the application
and it's certainly not something the
environmental health officer has
suggested or considers
necessary in this case
that's fine thank you okay lovely thank
you very much everyone
i'm not seeing any more questions uh in
our meeting chat
so we will move to the debate who would
like to kick us off
just give that a few more seconds again
my computer is still being painful
and so forgive me for that counselor
harry first please
thank you chairman well i actually think
the um case officers put a very
comprehensive report together um
i think it's been helpful to see that
the wheel is the same size as it was
last year
the operator put measures in place if
there were
concerns to complain i think
um in terms of the report it has
identified
um the the situation regarding
covet um and obviously
you know we are operating in uncertain
times
um looking at the
um proposal and the application that we
have in front of us
i actually can't see a planning reason
based on the officers committee report
and therefore i'm i'm quite comfortable
and happy to go with the proposal
of grant in line with the officer's
recommendation
marvelous thank you very much councillor
parry councillor jennings next please
hello councillor parry had stolen my
thunder
for a change how she does every time
um and uh yeah i she said everything
which i was going to say and i'm very
happy to second it
marvelous thank you very much cancer
kendall next please uh
everything's been said by the previous
two speakers happy to third
yeah let's consider it thirded
councilman mills next please
oh yes sir thanks mr chairman um
i had to say i've got concerns over this
as um
you know straight away is is it within
the air the uh consummate
conservation area area of restraint
and if you look at page five on the
report
um it says um
you've also got the got the uh
observation tower
at the rsc it cannot be compared with
that
it it's ridiculous it cannot be compared
with that
um to my mind is that i saw
when coming into um into stratford
again on page six um on the second
paragraph
uh it reports there'll be some harm
uh on the third paragraph will cause
harm
uh it says whilst the wheel does not
relate to his
local historic features or local
distinctiveness
it is generally attractive well i
disagree with that it's certainly not
attractive
um and it says here while the
development would affect
so admits it would affect the area when
i go on
um again on the um
on page six would harm heritage assets
assets public benefit i'm not sure where
the public benefit is
and it also says it says it will be an
impact
um on page seven it says again result in
some harm
and it goes on um in conclusion and
and planning balance you know we're not
blackpool i've got nothing aged
blackpool but we're certainly not
blackboard because we quit hats next
and on the second to last paragraph on
page nine
some it says some detrimental impact i
mean i
all the way through it says there will
be harm
um and i think somewhere
also in the um in the report it says
that
the wheel is is quite considerable
distance from uh
from residents um but you know people
have
i've seen people go up the uh on this
wheel with binoculars so
i'm sure they'd be able to view into
someone's balcony um
i i do realize that uh strategy economy
has been hit
badly by the when i covered but um you
know i don't think we have to set our
soul to make money i'll be very
interested to
see how much stratford does make out of
this
thank you very much mr chairman and uh
you can see where i'm going with this
um i would be against uh this uh to
grant this application thank you very
much
thank you that's my opinion thank you
very much cancer mills
um counselor adam next please
thanks chairman um i think this is
definitely one for
in terms of planning balance i mean some
things are a bit more cut and dry
whereas i think
councilor mills did touch on some of the
the things that clearly the local
residents are
um are concerned about and that's
something that one of the speakers did
speak of and uh speak on to a good
effect
i i must admit i um although i i cannot
appreciate those points i can't see um
that there's
overwhelming um planning a reason not
not to grant
one thing that does concern me slightly
though is the um this whole basis of
precedent almost that the um
environmental health
um department seemed to have used it in
assessing this
um what i mean by that is that if it
it was fine the first year and clearly
wasn't as noisy
um that would have given them
justification to not object to the
following year but
as we've heard from the ward member uh
it does look to have
got worse in terms of the noise impact
but the um but the previous year's
justification
doesn't seem um kept up to date with
that
um and i i think something that
counselor parry was um
asking uh the officers sort of touched
on on that concern as well
and although i'm not so
suggesting that you know that we go
against
this application i was wondering if we
could be
slightly more robust in monitoring the
um the noise aspect um and seeing if
there is something that we could do
uh in maybe conditioning it um to be
monitored slightly more uh robustly and
then
have that um something that we can do an
assessment on
um welcome thoughts from from
officers and members on that really
because that seems to be the main
concern that came up from the ward
members
the noise okay thank you very much
adam uh councillor crump next please
yeah just very briefly mr chairman um
it's um i think we do need uh i think it
will be an asset to the time um
it is interesting to note that the town
council has withdrawn its objection to
the scheme
and and obviously the same council um
can be
a vociferous uh critic of um
the district council or or
i perceive it in sunny saiyan i don't
always get the
uh get the the politics and i don't
always read the stratford hero because
it doesn't get delivered to uh to save
them but i do
read between the lines so um if i'm
doing anybody i miss justice
uh and injustice there um i i do
apologize but
it is interesting to know the ten
council have withdrawn its objection
i i think we do need to make sure that
we do try and regenerate
all the tens uh in warwickshire uh
and with stratford in particular being
hit you know the fourth
worst hit in the country with
significant reduction
in tory's income uh tourism income so
i think internal tourism may be
growing far more quickly than tourism
from overseas
and i i certainly think that we do need
i don't think we ask i don't know again
put in words in cancer mills um
math again an apologist i don't think we
are selling ourselves to the devil on
this one
uh i don't know where cancer mills
actually use those words but
um i i think we do need to make sure we
we think outside the box
and try and make sure our town centres
uh and the major royal centers in
stratford district are vibrant
you know um my one saith um
has been hit badly by being cut off by
hs2
um you know we would perhaps love this
around
this wheel but i can't imagine it coming
out
to southern so yeah i'm all in five of
trying to
regenerate our ten centers help them
grow
and i think this is a positive positive
sign
thank you council crime thank you very
much indeed um council adam you
sort of semi posed a question about
noise to our officers
i'm going to ask our officers if they
have any uh feedback they want to give
on that before we move to a vote
uh so charlotte uh or alex would you
like to comment on
council adam's question
shall i pick this one up charlotte and
the only thing
i was going to add really is that um i
understand where you're coming from
counselor adam but
environmental health will do a thorough
assessment of every application as it
comes in so
um they it wouldn't be the case that
that they would
look at the past conditions and say
that's sufficient obviously they do need
to look at any changes in specification
although i know this is the same wheel
that's been in place
uh from the applicant i understand from
the start albeit um councillor fragile
mentioned that the
the noise increased after the first year
um so i would i would just say that and
obviously they've raised no objection
and they've recommended the condition
relating to amplified music but nothing
relating to sort of a specific noise
level um the other thing i would say
that when
environmental health respond to
consultations they will have regard to
any complaints which have been received
so we don't actually have any
information before us tonight about
whether they have received any or if
they have the numbers
but they will have regard to that in
coming up with their consultation
response which as you know in this case
is one of no objection
um so i would suggest that any condition
which
sets a specific noise limit um
i think we'd struggle to justify it
against the six condition tests
uh but i would say that if members are
sort of insistent that they want to go
down that route is something which we
would need to agree with the
environmental health officer
so if members are minded to approve
subject to a tight
noise condition it may be something that
we can go away
and work with through environmental
health and agree perhaps through the
chairman
if if members do consider that to be
appropriate but like i said i
i i'd be slightly nervous about putting
such a condition
on any forthcoming planning commission
thank you very much alice um council
adam you do you want to come back on
that
okay thanks no that's really useful and
i think that's all gets to what i was
talking about
i think that the only thing i was going
to ask then in in follow-up to that is
because this is
um still a temporary permission that
they're seeking
but obviously over the five years would
it be worth looking at an
annual reassessment based on the
the running of the wheel i mean the only
thing i've been thinking is because it's
the same wheel and clearly the noise has
got worse over time
i wouldn't want us to not consider that
as
significant as a waiting planning
assessment
over that time and i don't know how
practical that is in terms of
the planning law of it um you know and
how
that mixes with the environmental health
aspect
that's it through new chair i think
again i i'd
um resist putting any sort of condition
on on the planning permission because
we've we've got
to repeat myself sorry the the response
from environmental health but
what i will say is you know going
forward if
we do end up getting a lot of complaints
from residents
and when i say we that's environmental
environmental health from a noise
perspective
the monitoring is likely to be something
that they would undertake anyway
just to test whether the complaints that
they're getting
are well-founded um and have
powers under their legislation to be
able to sort of
put measures in place to make any impact
acceptable so
i think in terms of the planning
permission i think the conditions that
are recommended
are sufficient to protect it going
forward but then there are other
uh sort of legislations and the
environment or how powers
are in place to be able to sort of
control anything going forward if it
does become more of an issue
okay thank you for that it's really
appreciated thank you alice
um i have two more speakers registered
to speak both have already spoken so
um i will ask you i'm gonna allow you
both to speak but please do keep it
concise because
we do need to get through uh through all
of our our business today so councilman
mills first of all
yeah thanks miss jim yes thanks for
allowing me to speak again
yeah yes i was just going to say you
obviously know i'm against this um
proposal um you know stratford is is
an historic town and people don't come
to to go up on a wheel
i mean i i i don't know where the idea
of a wheel came from except from the
uh for the owners of the wheel um people
come to
see a stratfor town you know and
shakespeare not not
a wheel um you know it's just um
to my mind appalling very well thank you
okay thank you council mills councillor
jennings your again same rules apply
very quick
and we're judging this application on
the details in front of us it's for five
years
so therefore it's not not for us to
start dictating whether it should be one
year reviewed or cetera
uh my certain fans are doing this every
year for five years um
so we're judging this application on the
on the details
which is there thank you all right yeah
i could i wholeheartedly agree with that
we are judging the application that is
in front of us
on the evidence that has been presented
to us um
one of our counselors suggested that it
is clear that the noise have got worse
i've got no evidence in front of me to
demonstrate that um so
um i i have to make a decision we all
have to make a decision on what's in
front of us now
we have a proposal um to grant from
councillor parry
that has been seconded by councillor
jennings and it has been thirded by
councillor kendall
um so let's move to a vote um i will go
first councillor richards
four thank you
councillor fleming councillor fleming
four
cue councillor adam castle adam four
monster kendall councillor kendall four
councillor crom council crump for
councilman dickson councillor dixon four
thank you councillor eden councillor
for councillor jennings
councillor jennings for you councillor
mills
councillor meals against and councillor
parry
councillor parry four
that's nine for chairman and this one
against
fabulous thank you very much and and
therefore members resolve to grant
application twenty one zero zero four
five six ful that is the recreation
ground car parks one's nest
lane marvelous um let's move on to our
next application which is application
reference 2100 395
full five to seven wood street in
stratford
our presenting offset is amy flutes
and before we move to amy um i'm just
going to ask whoever is
uh joining us on the phone if you could
please mute your handsets we are getting
some feedback
and if you could also please turn off
your live feed and follow on the phone
the live feed is delayed by about 10-15
seconds so you're a better place to
listen on the phone
rather than on the livestream at this
point
um forgive me amy uh you're our lovely
presenting officer
please whenever you're ready do feel
free to start
thank you chairman i will just um share
my screen with you so if you could just
let me know once you could see it i
would be appreciative
can you see that it's just loading now
yeah we've got it now thank you great
thank you
the application site edged with a black
line comprises grey two-listed buildings
five to seven wood street and part of
the public highway to their frontages
the site is within the town centre and
bill superior boundary of
stratford-upon-avon
the site is within the conservation area
the red
blocked color on the plan demonstrates
that the site is
in close proximity to many other listed
buildings
planning permission is sought for the
installation of 19 hostile vehicle
mitigation bollards to the frontage of 5
to 7 wood streets along with associated
extension to the footway
the hatched area where my cursor is
indicates the extent of the footwear
extension
and carriageway narrowing to the north
the blue dots indicate the location of
the bollards the 19 bollards will be
approximately
1.065 meters in height above ground
level
spaced approximately 1.2 meters apart
over a length of 31 meters across the
street frontage
they would be constructed from steel and
the plans indicate that the bollards
will be black in colour and have
reflective strips on them
proposed elevations um are now being
shown which show what the bollards will
look like in situ
in front of the buildings that they are
proposed to protect
this image is taken looking in a south
easterly direction towards the southern
side of wood street where 5-7 wood
street can be seen
this image is taken looking in a
southwesterly direction towards the
southern side of wood street again where
5 to 7 wood street can be seen
and finally this image is taken looking
in us sorry and finally the width of the
existing footpath on the south side of
wood street can now be seen to the
frontage of the building
by virtue of the number location size
and design of the bollards the proposal
is considered to cause harm to the
character of the conservation area and
setting of numerous listed buildings and
impact the immunity of the street scene
it is not considered that there are
sufficient public benefits to outweigh
the identified harm
chairman the recommendation is to refuse
the application as detailed
in the committee report thank you amy
thank you very much
for that we will move straight to our
first speaker
we have the agent for the application mr
andrew wilkes
mr wilkes are you there you may need to
press on six to unmute your keypads
let's start and six to unmute mr welts
hi can you hear me okay we can indeed
now i've got on my
uh on my form in front of me that it's
yourself but you're also joined by uh mr
uh burbidge is that correct uh i'm
joined by
charlie prydle and mr burb chess okay
and then let's answer questions you'll
be doing the speaking is that right
that's right fabulous okay well you have
three minutes we'll give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up um
otherwise whenever you're ready please
do feel free to start
thank you good evening chair councillors
and officers
pragnal is a stratford-upon-avon
institution established in 1954
employing 55 people pregnant
is a brand synonymous with a town people
travel from afar to visit
and prada brings much-needed quality
vibrancy and diversification to the high
street
and plays a significant role in
contributing towards a local economy
ram raiding is the new significant
security risk
to prized high street assets such as
pragma
this crime has happened to other similar
retailers and represents a horrible
life-threatening life-threatening event
that can seriously injure or kill
staff customers and the public as the
circulated photos show
ram raiding can cause significant damage
with this listed
timber frame building that damage could
compromise the building's structural
integrity
this is potentially a far greater harm
to the building
than the neutral harm caused by the
bollards
this application is fully supported by
the police and looks to make as minimal
impact as possible
pre-app discussions with highways board
councillors and accessibility stratford
have delivered a scheme that
implements a 20 miles per hour speed
limit ensures the safety of pedestrians
and road users
provides the required level of safety
for staff customers and the public
and protects the frontage of this listed
building from the threat
of ram raids the pavement will be two
meters wide and will facilitate the safe
movement of pedestrians
whilst retaining sufficient width for
two lorries to pass
this application does not affect the
listed building's fabric
the design has been carefully considered
and will preserve
and enhance the street scene it is off a
very high conservation standard and
wholly suitable
for sensitive historic locations such as
this
the high street is on its knees and
collectively
we need to do everything possible to
help trade pragnal
embraces its role as a key strategic
anchor retailer to the town
and whilst there is a genuine desire to
continue to continue to invest in
stratford
this application really is the watershed
moment
the london outlet is working well and if
support for this application
isn't forthcoming then investment will
need to be directed out of town
jobs will be moved and there will be a
significant reduction in the inflow of
affluent customers to stratford
bollards are not an alien concept and
are seen throughout stratford town
the implications of not approving this
application are significant
pragnal are a responsible employer who
need to limit the risk of fatality to
staff customers and the public
it really is that serious to conclude
these proposals have a neutral impact on
the setting of a listed building
the bollards will protect the building
and people from this unfortunate issue
and approving this application will
allow this anchor retailer
to play a key role assisting stratford
with a post-pandemic recovery
all of the benefits from this
application are significant the impact
is neutral and we respectfully request
that you approve this application
failure to do so will be contrary to
your policies cs 22
23 and 24. thank you
mr works thank you very much for that
members do we have any questions
for our speaker please you could
indicate in the chat if you do
councilman mills first please yeah thank
you very much
uh good evening um i i notice on the um
the picture at the uh photograph of the
bottom of the
uh uh the slides there um
i think they've got bollards there um
it doesn't seem to have stopped the ram
raiding um i'm not sure where
that is is it um i don't know uh
it's not strapped but it's got bollards
there hasn't it and it's
doesn't seem to have stopped this tract
or whatever it is
um i'm not sure whether the bollards
would actually
have anybody's really intent of uh
crashing through them i don't know but
it
they are balanced there aren't there
[Music]
the question is exactly where the
bollards are placed in response to the
question
and the uh the nature of the bollard
we've been informed by the police that
the bollard that needs to be installed
is the pat
68 bollard which is the anti-terrorist
bollard
and set at the right distance and gives
full protection
um as you'd expect we've investigated
this very thoroughly and this is
the most secure solution yeah thank you
but
thank you very much that's great that's
interesting thank you
okay uh members are you know another
couple of seconds if anyone else has any
more questions
please indicate in the chat if you do
otherwise we will move on
give you a couple of seconds
that looks like a no um so mr wilkes
thank you very much for your time
and also to mr pragma and mr berbich who
have joined you um
again as you've heard with uh previous
speakers you're probably in our best
place to continue to follow the live
stream
uh so you can hang up your handset now
but thank you for your contributions
thank you thank you very much um
okay we will move to our ward member who
is our next speaker tonight
and that is councillor jenny fragley
councillor fragili are you there
yeah thank you chair good evening um
you know the drill we you've got five
minutes 30 second warning stay on for
questions if you would whenever you're
ready do feel free to start
thank you very much um i have received a
briefing from john carford head of
policy
i thought that wise as i have mentioned
economic viability and vitality in my
brief statement
on the planning portal and i wish to
check sdc
thinking in this area and its possible
impact on planning decisions
i was also keen to ensure that this
application came to committee
as it involves a well-established
locally based business
with a global reach and they are
entitled to make their argument
in public in the public arena
in the past i've always been concerned
about placing bollards here
and have asked for alternative ideas to
give the assurance pragnals have always
sought
this application is different in a
number of ways from previous
applications
highways have examined the impact on
pavement and road safety
and have raised no objections this is a
material fact
as well as consideration accessible
stratford
have a concern we motorize mobility
scooters
that are comfortable with the space for
buggies wheelchairs and pedestrians
i note that there are bollards across
stratford
in ely street scholars lane and high
street
indeed i see similar bollards in many
historic towns
with similar pavement widths
black bollards are a feature in many
historic towns
preventing parking on pavements and
sadly recently security against
ram raiding and terrorist attacks
indeed terrorist mitigation is already a
feature of our town
in henley street a major change in the
town
is the impact of covid19
our town has suffered a devastating blow
to its premier industry
with an observable downturn impact in
the town center
we need to rethink think our approach to
recovery
ensuring that key retail businesses
remain
and thrive providing a framework
fundamental to regeneration
we have an economy based on
international tourism
which will not return to previous levels
soon but we must
conserve our assets for that upturn
the town center will not be the standard
chain retail environment it has been
it will need to build a confident
framework of established businesses
town center living opportunities for
local enterprise independent
and destination enterprise and i'm
assured by the head of policy
that this is a material consideration in
the planning process
and should play a part in your
discussions
may i add a comment from joe baking a
director of stratford business
improvement he says pragma's presence
and national and international draw for
the town center
has helped ensure a high level of visits
and spend in the town
that might otherwise go elsewhere in
addition
wood street area has become a jewellery
quarter
anchored around pragma's presence the
bid executive
director supports the application to
ensure the continued economic success of
the town centre
i would urge the committee to think
about pragmas as one of the key
businesses
and the bollards as part of street
furniture of safety
it is a balanced decision possibly
highways has no ejection
objection and the impact of covered 19
has indeed shifted the balance
thank you
thank you very much councillor frasier i
hope everyone can hear me my my computer
is still playing
to apologize it doesn't tell me when
i've been muted unmuted can someone give
me a thumbs up say that i am
you can hear me fabulous thank you sorry
about that everybody
um castle frankie thank you very much um
we'll just check now see if we have any
questions for you councillor parry has
come in first of all answer parry
thank you chair and good evening
councillor fragile and thank you very
much for
such a comprehensive um ward members
report
um and i can i can hear some passion in
your voice as well and you've
clearly done some research with um
obviously organizations in stratford um
i noticed that the town council
um submitted a no representative
comment obviously your conversations
have included the town council i just
wondered
it's it's unfortunate they're not here
to um
get their views um about it
but i just wondered whether the town
council had got
anything further to say following the
additional research that
and contact that you've made with other
organizations in stratford
i was present at the discussion of this
at the time council
and when the vote was taken there was
one
councillor that was vehemently opposed
and so it was felt that the town council
couldn't put a unanimous
uh approval and so went for no reps
to accommodate the uh single counsellor
that was opposed to this proposal
so chair if i may can you just advise
then how many
um other councils councillors
might have were in favor of it you say
there was one councillor that went
against it
can you i
i can't remember exactly how many people
present but it should be nine
nine people on the um plus the mayor so
so there were ten present
okay thank you i can't swear to that but
i understand there were ten present
thank you okay thank you very much both
councillor crump next please
um my question to cancer fragility is is
about
bollards and i think probably people
talk i think i took bollards a lot of
the time but
hopefully this is a sensible question um
i noticed um
you mentioned in your representation
that the bollards are removable
um was that discussed at the um yeah
in your award um on page 17 the bombards
are removable and if and when the town
advances ideas for a more friendly
pedestrian environment all the solutions
might be available
um was that discussed with
um with people such as accessible
stratford
just for their views as well because
obviously yeah
again having the flexibility of
removable bollards
um is great but again have they got the
integrity if i removable to withstand
um impacts of terrorism etc
so i haven't i haven't had this precise
discussion but it has been part of
discussions
with a number of people that possibly
could be removable
but i think it's removable in the sense
that
uh there are a number of ideas uh
developing
with the three councils town district
and county about regeneration of the
town center
and quite possibly with some of those
regeneration ideas and reconfiguration
it might actually prove like henry
street
an option not to have bollards exactly
outside a shop
but in another position but they would
have to be the um
uh terrorist strength bollards
yeah there's no point in putting up
bolognese that don't actually do the job
uh mr mr chairman can i just come back
with a slightly uh additionally
again this is this is no pun intended
you weren't vlogging but
basically cancer fragile you're saying
that the bollards are not
set in stone it's it's it's potentially
serious this is genuine but it's um
that's a question for the officer to
clarify rather than for councillor
fragile
uh for sure but we'll do that during the
officers clarification points in a
second if that's okay
um council fragile following on from
what you've just said that the town
council with district and county are
considering
wider measures um would it be fair to
say that we might be jumping the gun
if we were to approve this given the
there's the probability of
other measures coming forward or is that
an unfair thing to think
i think that's unfair to say because we
all know that any future development is
dependent on so many things
that might be two three four five years
in advance depending on
our money and and feasibility but i do
think that pragnals
actually need the confidence now to
continue their business
with these bollards in place okay that's
fair comment
okay thank you very much um there didn't
there don't appear to be any more
questions for you so
uh thank you very much for your
contribution this evening again you you
can stay on
and continue to watch um from from where
you are now
um let's go to officer points of
clarification
um amy i think we might have one about
whether the balance of settings don't
would you mind coming back to us on that
please yeah
so um the applicants have applied um for
the bollards to be
permanent in nature and if i just share
with you
um my screen i can share with you the
proposed plans
which show that they are obviously going
to be
built um below ground level quite
considerably which would
make me think that they are more
permanent um
than being able to be removed um on a
sort of temporary basis
okay thank you very much uh councillor
crump are you you're happy
thumbs up fabulous counselor parry has a
question for you as well please
thank you amy um obviously this is a
uh it came across when when the papers
landed very much a unique
um application uh for the town centers
so i just
happened to do a bit of a quick google
at the weekend just to see
what what other towns or cities might be
doing
um and i just wondered whether you were
aware that the national
gallery which sits in trafalgar square
which is grade one listed
in a conservation area had planning
approval for anti-terrorist bollards
literally within the last couple of
weeks
and also not too far not
not too recent well not that
long ago um the windsor castle ward
and the town center have had also
uh bollards anti-terrorism
bollards put in front of um
some grade two listed buildings for
their protection
and i just wondered whether um
you and the conservation officer would
have um
been aware that this obviously because
sadly we live in the world that we do
um but in a nutshell
if it's good enough for the national
gallery and trafalgar square is a great
one listed conservation area
um i just wondered whether the
conservation officer
and the planning team were aware of what
was going on down in trafalgar square
and also at windsor castle
which again is another tourist area
um thank you councillor so as part of
the design and access statement um
there was a bit of a brochure about the
bollards and it did make reference to
other locations across the uk where
these have have been used
and what i would say is that obviously
every application is assessed on its own
merits
um so there may have been um public
benefits
specific to those cases which obviously
allowed for them to be put forward
um as part of this application whilst
obviously officers
as stated in the report recognize that
there are some public benefits
and it's not considered that there are
wider public benefits and the benefits
are
quite private in nature for this case
okay thank you very much uh councilman
mills has a question for you as well
please
yeah thanks mr uh amy um do you think
you could put the um
the plan up there the photograph of
where the proposed bollards are going to
be
please i'm just trying to get a visual
i'm looking at that
that's great it must be about four in
the morning no cars um
right thank you now can you put yeah
now can you put the the plan up showing
the the bollards
please
and then 19 of them yes 19 correct
okay that's lovely thank you very much
thank you
okay marvis are there any more questions
for clarification for our officer
please if you could indicate in the chat
if there are give you 10 seconds
we're not seeing a lot of action
counselor adam
please thanks hopefully a very quick one
um obviously in the report it does talk
about other bollards across the town
um but this is a very specific type of
ballard how do they compare visually
would you say i mean that i'm imagining
they can
range from sort of fairly substantial
anti-terrorist ones to
more traditional ones how do they
compare
um thank you councillor i can share a
screen of the ones um
which are um sort of within the media
vicinity so this is the one which is at
crooks alley
which you can see is um just a singular
metal
or large um and then the one
and the bollards as you go into um
valcourts they are if you can just see
these
two timber structures um there is
as i stated in the report there is a
variety of bollards of styles throughout
stratford
and obviously they are in um their
locations where they are required but
obviously their
um amount number and concentration isn't
necessarily
um to the extent of what is proposed in
this is part of the street scene
thanks very much thank you very much amy
would you mind flicking back to
uh slide 10 for me because my machine
didn't shirt
oh hopefully it is going to show it's
just suddenly i've got a black screen
there we go thank you very much yeah
okay lovely thank you
um okay um if we've got no further
questions for our officer we will move
into
the debate who would like to kick us off
councillor jennings first please
thanks chairman and when wood street was
built
criminals wouldn't ram raid shops with
horses and carts
but the world's changed uh now they
steal tractors and diggers
we'll drive them straight into buildings
and when they do this and they can
demolish buildings
but more importantly they pose a danger
not just to the lives of the people who
are in the shops or
above it but also pedestrians who are
walking past
i mean they just drive straight in it's
sort of it's a real danger you see it
all the time on the news and
then again and especially these days i
mean i think bollards are a thing which
everyone sees
and with terrorism ram racing when you
see that the airports
train stations i think they're also
outside downing street
um i'm buckingham palace i'm sure and so
they're the norm
and and they give a sense of security to
the public
and the the applicants seem to have
worked closely with the police
um and they've also tried to make these
bollards as well camouflaged as possible
i mean black i think it's a traditional
color and i had a quick
i had a quick search on this when i had
the application through and i think
the east india company originally used
old cannons
from warships and they they put those
outside the building outside their
building in london as a form of
protection
um and our policies again they encourage
us to support businesses
especially coming out of covid um
and this uh in my view there it gives
the application gives security to theirs
and safety to the staff
shop visitors pedestrians the widening
of the footpath gives additional public
safety
and public benefits slowing the cars
down to 20 miles now
in my view again is yet another
additional benefit
um i don't see these bollards as causing
any visual harm at all to the listed
building or heritage
i don't see i don't see them as
detrimental at all
um i'd like to propose that we go
against the officer's recommendation
here on this occasion
and grant this application marvis thank
you very much councillor jennings
councilman mills next please
thanks mr chairman yes um well look
first look to this
uh application i had my reservations um
regarding 19 bollards but
i i i agreed with a lot with what matt
was saying
um times had changed and
murphy's law if we said no they're not
going to have these uh bollards
tomorrow or whatever somebody's going to
come along and ram raid it and then
they're going to say to the stratfor
judicial council i told you so
um i i i i can just see it it's just
murphy's law
um i'm quite happy to second
um councillor jennings's um proposal mr
chairman
thank you thank you very much council uh
adam next please
thanks chairman um i think broadly i
agree with the
previous two speakers um
something that comes to mind is um the
conservation i think
can't just be seen as um
preserving something exactly as it is i
think it's got to be
viewed through the lens of actually
conserving the benefit
i mean if we kind of kept it exactly as
it was we wouldn't have the tarmac
on the road sort of thing so i think we
have to kind of
look at the conservation aspect of this
which is obviously a significant part of
the application
um in that light i think i
i do appreciate the impact that these
will have but i can see
why they are being proposed and i can
also see that
there's been some attempt to to maintain
a
visual aesthetic that isn't too abrasive
or
in indistinct with with the surrounding
area and i can also say from
from personal experience that these
these ram raids do happen i mean one
happened in the village i live in
i was one of the first people on the
scene and i mean that was just co-op
so i did then think what might happen to
this
um this business if it were attacked by
that um
so yeah broadly speaking i i do um agree
that
although i completely understand the the
reservations that the planning officer
has i
in terms of balance i'd say i fall on
the side of granting this application
um and i'm i'm so
i would have proposed or seconded but um
the only thing i'd say is i'm
trying to work out the exact um core
strategy
um clause to justify that because i have
a feeling that's something that's going
to come up from the officers momentarily
okay thank you very much council adam
i'm sure we can help people with that
shortly um councillor dixon next
please uh thank you chairman yes uh
stratfor the historic town black
bollards do feature in historic towns
these will provide protection for a
listed building which
as we were advised by i think it was mr
wilkes
indicated that an iran raid whilst apart
from the damage to the jewelers
and uh possibly to to personnel um
the damage to a timber-framed listed
building
could be extremely detrimental indeed um
essentially
uh councillor jennings and mills said
everything that they need to
obviously the bid i gather support of
this and
i too will be in favor of granting this
application
thank you chair thank you very much
councillor uh councillor parry next
please thank you chairman well i think
um the previous speakers have said a lot
of what i was going to say
um i i would just like to commend
the ward member for making such an
excellent representation
for um very detailed
um the fact that she's gone to seek
additional advice through
our policy team and spoken to the bid
um we have the town council which
clearly there were eight representative
councillors on board
with one against which was a reason why
they felt that they couldn't support it
i think at the end of the day you know
pragnals are are
are through and through um an anchor
store
uh an anchor outlet in stratford
um and i think demonstrating
that we i do think whilst there is some
harm
that is way it is outweighed
by the public benefit and the public
benefit
is adding safety and actually
preservation
of the buildings of our listed buildings
and the heritage of the town
by protecting them with the installation
of the bollards so i think
that those elements actually
contribute to um how
outweighing the any any harm which i
don't
believe is substantial um and i'm in
favor that and i think anything that
will reduce
traffic down by 20 miles per hour has to
be
welcomed and we have an application that
is not
has no objection by highways although
they've recommended
they've put forth some recommendations
and it is being welcomed by the police
plus you know what's good enough for the
national gallery in trafalgar
square grade one listed conservation
area
as well as windsor castle ward
i think should be good enough for
stratford so
i'm i'm for this for granting this
application thank you chair
thank you very much mr parry uh
councillor crump next please
thank you mr chairman on the previous
application i i supported the efforts to
to attract visitors uh to the town
uh to help to ensure we've got a healthy
and vibrant town center
certainly i can see parallel hours with
this
uh with pragnals being the key business
uh
and people coming uh as councillor
francis said
um from from all parts to
to visit um certainly i think we
we do need to ensure our key businesses
remind and thrive
and again we we're trying to conserve
our assets for
for the upturn so i think there are
several important points there
um living along say living a fair
distance from
from stratford and i don't visit as
often as some members i'm often reliant
on the ward member
for their local experience and knowledge
and
as as coach apparently said that council
fragility spoke very eloquently
and weighed up the balance as well and
then gave a view of the town council
i've got community safety at the the
county and it's interesting to note that
that the police support this um and as
this been said by previous speakers
um i would wouldn't want anything to
happen
from a terrorism or or hostile
act um to happen because we haven't done
this
um certainly therefore i will be
supporting the application
and and um
so yeah i will be supporting the
application sorry thank you
cancer crime thank you very much um i'll
check in my two panels worth now before
we uh we move forward
um i must admit when i first saw this uh
application i did have my reservations
um
on two uh two things really first of all
the highway uh the fact that we're
losing an element of the highway
in an area where in my opinion it is
already extraordinarily tight
buses turning off the main roundabout up
towards
uh pragnals have to come across the
other side of the road and now with an
extra loss
of highway my concern is there could be
increased traffic
um uh collision potential for collisions
um
having said that we do have a no
objection from highways and they are the
experts
so i i do have to take the evidence that
they've put in front of us um as
gospel um i also had a concern about the
the style and designing of the of these
whilst i recognize they are used widely
across the country
um and the national gallery and winter
castle are
clearly um very well known buildings
um and yes one could say if if they're
good enough for them they're good enough
for stratford
one could also uh say well i would
suggest the national gallery
central london trafalgar square and uh
windsor castle
are probably more likely and this is in
no way diminishing the importance of
george wagner's
uh but probably more likely to be a
target for um
for ram raiding or terrorist acts um
we still need to consider it in this
location so we do not have to consider
it
in its on its own merits um i'm not
convinced
yet that bollards throughout the town
or or just in this location um are the
right thing for stratford
um if we have a wider scheme
uh that is designed to prevent uh
terrorist attacks in
the center of town through either
vehicle uh tax or similar
um i'd be certainly more amenable to
that uh but as we've also heard from the
ward member that
could well be a long way off and we do
have to consider the
the protection of the high street in
particular protection of that building
now um having listened to what everyone
has said
uh and considered all the evidence has
been presented i'm actually now more
minded to support
um and go along with the proposal that
has been put by councillor jennings and
councillor mills
we are going against the officer's
recommendation so we do need to be very
clear
as to why we're going against that
officer's recommendation
and the policies in which we're using to
support those
i've made a few notes and and i will
hopefully this will summarize them for
you councillor jennings and councillor
mills and for the benefit the rest of
the committee so
um in essence um we would be going
against the officer's recommendation
because the committee believes
and this is of course if we agree to
this uh committee believes that it is in
the public benefit
that there is public benefit uh to the
installation of these bollards
by virtue of their safety both in terms
of um pedestrian safety but also highway
safety uh highway safety being
the reduction of the speed to a 20 mile
an hour zone along that strip
and also the preservation of a listed
building
um i also believe that we talked about
um the supporting of businesses
and particularly sporting businesses in
town centers i believe
and i'm sure our officers will correct
me if i'm wrong that would be policy cs
22
of the core strategy um so those would
be the reasons that we're putting
council jennings can you give me a
confirmation that that is
uh a decent summary of your proposal
okay thank you chairman you took the
words right out of my mouth word for
word
fabulous councillor mills are you happy
with that as sir seconder
yes absolutely um's chairman you can say
this is a julian the crown
this one thank you fabulous thank you
very much
um okay uh if i could please ask
our planning managers to confirm that
you you are happy with the reasons that
we've put and to add anything you may
wish to add
yes thank you chairman and i think the
only thing i just wanted to clarify
um was obviously we've identified a
number of public benefits there and
you've helpfully listed those and that's
consistent with the notes i took
i think the only thing i'd just like to
clarify is whether members are
concluding that there is
harm to heritage assets are you less
than substantial harm but that the
public benefits outweigh that harm
or that there's no harm to heritage
assets
i would suggest the former but i will
ask councillor jennings to confirm
his view as the proposal i'm happy to go
with the former then
castle mills you're happy extremely mr
chairman
fabulous good stuff okay in that case i
think we can probably move to a vote
well i would say before we do
um i'm sure our portfolio holder uh will
take this away but if we could
uh progress a uh a wider scheme
uh for protection of the town center uh
in
in line with this i think that would be
a um a very positive thing um
i have just been reminded by both our
legal officer and our uh planning
officer that we haven't talked about
conditions
so um amy would you mind running through
the standard conditions and anything you
think we should be adding in
sorry chairman i forgot i was still on
mute
so um you will see from the officer
report
um that highways only have um no
objection
subject to um satisfactory agreement of
a
legal agreement to secure six thousand
pounds to be paid
to um county highways prior to the
commencement development
to secure a contribution towards the
reduction of the carriageway speed
um so i think um if members are
obviously minded to approve it
um any permissions should be subject to
the satisfactory
satisfactory agreement of um that
section 106 being secured
um and then for conditions for the
planning permission obviously once that
has been secured
we would probably be looking for um
development to
um be commenced within three years
development to be carried out in
accordance with the um approved drawings
um the bollards a condition which
restricts the color of the bollards
and to being black and that they are
maintained
in that colour in perpetuity and also a
condition
um which and secures um that
um the bollards um shall not be
installed above ground level until the
associated widening of the footway and
narrowing of the carriageway has been
laid out
and constructed in general accordance
with um
the relevant plan um to be approved
um and also with regards to notes and
just
noting um national planning policy
framework and also
um highways in their response and did
request a note relation
relating to section 278 works
okay thank you i'm happy with those
councillor jennings cancer mills if you
could confirm as well please
yep happy with those thank you that's
the chinese casa yes um yeah
i'm happy as well miss chan thank you
externally happy as councilman
fabulous stuff thank you very much
indeed okay let's move to a vote so the
proposal is to grant
um application 2100 395 ful
proposed by cancer jennings seconded by
cancer mills the reasons we have given
i will go first council richards four
thank you councillor fleming councillor
fleming for
thank you councillor adam
adam four thank you councillor kendall
councillor kendall ford council crumb
council for councillor dixon
councillor dixon for councillor eden
councillor eddon four councillor
jennings
professor jennings paul councillor mills
council mills four nintendo
unanimous chairman thank you very much
anne um in that case
uh committee resolves to grant
application twenty one zero zero three
nine five ful fifty
five two seven wood street instructor by
even for the reasons given
marvelous thank you very much everybody
for that um let's move to our final
application of the evening
um and it would seem our final um online
virtual application as well
um the application reference is twenty
one zero zero two two
five f u l that is oscar house in oscar
banbury
um our presenting officer is joe brooke
joe over to you
thanks chair uh let me just upload the
presentation
hello can you hear me uh we speak is
that mr
uh birstall
hello can you hear me hello mr burstle
um we are
good evening and welcome we are just
going to have our officer present
the application to us i'm going to place
you on mute for the time being
and if you can follow one on your
handset rather than on a live stream
that would be helpful
there's a delay to the live stream and i
will call you to speak
um when we are uh when we're ready for
you you'll need to press star on six at
that point to unmute but for the time
being we're going to mute you
while we uh while we have the
presentation from our officer
okay um joe forgive me
when are you ready thank you i take it
all members can see that
uh i've got a black screen at the moment
my computer
i can see it i can see it
okay my machine will catch up
uh anyway thanks jeff the site is
located in the small village of oscar
as indicated by the black dot for you
the application is seeking retrospective
permission to create a new access track
to serve the stable yard at ascot house
the application is proposed to be
sighted to the east of the great
two-star listed old scout house within
the adjacent field
to the east of the grey two garden wall
ratings and gate pier
associated with ascot house and directly
adjacent to the old scott
conservation area so this is the
retrospective truck
oscar house and this is the approved
stable building is the rear
obviously coming off ascot road to gain
and
to the stables google earth imagery just
so it gives you a clearer picture
so obviously this is a bit old this is
where the stables
are positioned this is the existing
field access
now where the access track is laid and
this is oscar house itself
and the associated buildings
this is the photo of the gateway on the
associated truck
so oscar host is slightly over here this
is the art buildings to it and you can
see in the background stable buildings
that have just been
erected
gives you a more clearer picture of it
that's the second entrance point into
the old skirt estate
house estate sorry and also leads down
to the buildings
clearer picture in the adjacent field
with fence in
this is a view taken on oscar road
facing to the west you can see the gate
is open and the associated wall
and this is a view taken going to into
oscar itself
that's the end of the presentation i sat
in the officers report and in
consideration of highways assessment the
application is considered calls undue
harm to the safety existing highway
network
and our search posture recommendation is
for refusal
there are no updates and that is it
thank you
joe thank you very much um hopefully you
can see and hear me i've had to switch
devices
can you confirm that you can see and
hear me
fabulous okay in that case um counselor
burstol
uh is on the line for us he's our first
speaker council burst if you press start
and six
to unmute yourself we should be able to
hear you
hello hopefully you can uh hello good
evening good evening
uh so mr vessel you have three minutes
we'll give you a 30 second warning and
whenever you're ready please do feel
free to start
thank you chairman good evening
councillors my name's mark burstall
i'm chairman of warmington and asked at
parish council
i'm really very surprised that this
issue has reached the planning committee
since we could not see any reason for an
application to be made in the first
place
this is not a new access it has been in
place for well over 30
years contrary to highway's initial
assertion
they do not own the virgin aalsgut
since supplying them with a copy of the
parish council's title deeds highways
have now confirmed to me
in an email dated the 26th of march that
indeed they do not own it
the entire grassed area between the road
and the wall is the property of the
parish council
the applicant's use of the parrot
gateway is governed by a legal agreement
with the parish council in the same way
as all the other access points to ascot
house
which crossed the village green this
agreement also places a contractual
obligation on the owners of ascot house
to maintain parts of the green including
the verge alongside the paddock
the applicant has not altered the access
gate itself at all
but has put down a crushed limestone
hardcore surface
to prevent damage to the paddock and the
verge when any vehicles are driven
or horses are ridden over it in time
this will mellow down and blend in
as have all the other access tracks in
the village
the applicant suggested laying the
hardcore as a solution to a different
problem
in that when in that when using the
other wrought iron gate about 15 meters
further to the east
they found that in order to line up with
the wrought iron gates which are
narrower than the wooden one leading
into the paddock
they were having to swing round over the
opposite verge causing significant
damage to the verge
we believe highways is wrong to suggest
that laying this hardcore will resist
result in increased traffic the access
has been in use for as long as i can
remember for all types of vehicles
including oil tankers and sewage tankers
servicing the oil tanks
and septic tank both of which are
situated in the paddock
horse boxes have made use of this and
the adjacent wrought iron gates for many
years
and hunt used to meet in this parrot
regularly for many years
a few years ago a local farmer put in a
new field gate just outside the village
of the eastern end of the green
sighted less than one meter from the
roadway and giving no room for any
vehicle at all
to pull off before opening the gate this
is in the section of road that is less
wide
than at the applicant's gateway when
alerted to this by the parish council
highways stated they were not concerned
moving the daytona would be unsightly
and not at all in keeping with the grade
two-star listed
house and its cartilage or with the
oscar conservation area
it is worth noting that the horse box
that has caused highways so much concern
is no longer based in allscott thank you
mr uh councillor burstle thank you very
much for that if you bear with us when i
see if any of our members have any
questions for you members if you could
indicate in the chat
please if you do
maybe a few seconds just to do that
i'm not seeing a lot of movement so i'm
going to assume that that isn't no
uh in which case councilor versatile
thank you very much for your
contribution this evening and you're
probably now best placed to hang up your
handset and continue to watch on the
live stream but thank you very much for
your
contribution thank you chairman thank
you
okay our next speaker then um is miss
hannah mclaughlin uh miss mclaughlin are
you there
you may need to press star and sixth one
mute yourself
just to reiterate hello good evening we
can hear you
welcome okay thank you very much
no problem at all you probably know the
drill by now so you've got three minutes
to speak uh we'll give you a 30 second
warning before you get to the end
otherwise whenever you're ready
you're free to to start lovely um
good evening councillors um i'm the
planning agent for mr and mrs anderson
who have submitted this retrospective
application for a track
and upgraded access into their paddocks
adjacent to alisko house
the track uses an existing field gate
from the road and connects it connects
to the muck heap and stable building to
the rear of the field
it is constructed with a crushed
limestone surfacing which was selected
to reflect the other driveways and
tracks found in the village
and within the conservation area use of
the surfacing
is supported by the parish council the
purpose of the track
is twofold as previously set out by
councillor bertal
firstly the existing entrance to
arlascott house is too narrow for the
lorry to turn into and out of the
property
without um traversing onto the grass
verge to the south
as shown on the screen in figure one the
grass verge is an important feature of
the village and following concerns
raised by the community the applicants
had been using the field gate as an
alternative
the second reason is to enable the
applicant to transport horses to the
stable building without churning up the
pasture during wetter winter months
the condition of the fields last winter
for example is shown in figure 2.
the principle of the application was
considered to be acceptable
by the planning authority but is
presented to the committee today due to
concerns that the horse lorry cannot
park fully off the road when it is
waiting for the gate to be opened
the results of the overhang this results
in the overhang
as shown in figure 3.
the applicants have sought advice from a
highways consultant who has confirmed
that despite this overhang there is
sufficient intervisibility
for oncoming vehicles to see cars
traveling from the opposite direction
before committing to a maneuver for
reference
views of the access from the west and
east are provided in figure 4 and figure
5
which show how the waiting lorry would
be seen from a distance
you will see that this section of road
benefits from being relatively straight
with
wide verges and a low traffic flow the
highways authority has requested that
fencing is constructed within the
paddocks to push the gate back from the
highway
however this was not a desirable
approach given the character of the site
and they establish a historic field
boundary
which is lined by the stone wall
the track will have no impact on the
number of vehicles accessing the
property
as it will be a private semi-regular use
from one
horse lorry which as previously
mentioned is currently
um kept elsewhere and a waste removal
vehicle for accessing the muck heap
day-to-day domestic traffic will use the
main entrance to arloscope house as it
does currently
on the basis of this secondary use it is
proposed to keep the gate in its current
position
however the applicants would be open to
installing a wooden electric gate which
would allow the gate to be opened as
the lorry approaches the property
thereby reducing the
the waiting time thank you for your time
mr mclaughlin thank you very much i will
seek uh questions from our counselors
now before you go so counselors do you
have any questions for our agent
please you'll indicate in the chat if
you do
i'm not seeing a lot of movement so i'm
going to assume that's a no so uh mr
mclaughlin thank you very much for your
contribution this evening once again
your best place to
continue to watch the live stream so you
can hang up your handset whenever you
are ready
thank you okay our last speaker of the
evening is councillor fielding who has
been patiently waiting since the start
so council philly you know the drill
five minutes 30 second warning stay on
for questions whenever you're ready
i'm ready when when i get the picture of
the gate which is what i'm hoping to
start
this proceedings with there's a white
[ __ ] we have here a humble gate
and gateway that's been used over the
centuries the field boundary is
a stone wall that is part of the
cartilage of the listed property of
olscott house it was used by charles the
first at the time of the battle
of edge hill and a pane of glass bears
his signature
the planning officer under the
principles of development stated
in his final paragraph that i consider
the principle of the proposal
proposed development is acceptable but
it is subject to relevant
material consideration
cs26 which he referred to transport and
communications
b uh part b development will only be
permitted if the necessary mitigation is
provided against
any unacceptable transport impact
which arises directly from the
development
section section 2 ensures the scan of
the traffic generated
by the proposal is appropriate for the
function
and standard of the road servicing the
area the road that runs through
also house or through the village of
oscar sorry
is typical of an agricultural highway
few cars that use this road is mainly
local
in nature um i don't know whether i'm
sorry
um joe can you put up the other two
pictures showing the
view from the gate either way
as you can see there is a clear
visibility a few trees
um both ways the applicant
and their agent have outlined sighting
along the road
i discussed this matter with this
discuss matter of the large horse box
it's parked elsewhere for most of the
summer
and will return in the autumn it's used
for transporting polo ponies
and the polo season only lasts through
the summer months
the gate will be opened two or three
times a week
a man sorry which cannot be classed as
excessive use
i understand the concern of the highways
but this is a narrow road with good
visibility from the gate
i cannot see this as being a danger to
other users
i drive the road regularly it's not one
that you can speed on it's a single
track
wet carriageway and you must be very
careful about ongoing traffic
because it's just not wide enough to
pass the vehicles without
going into the verge the owners have
been there for four years
and they've had to take time to sort out
um their new arrangements with their
horses etc
and now they're in this position the
horse the
polo ponies are sorted elsewhere the
hunters
are and livery at the moment says very
very occasionally that any large vehicle
will come out of this
normally it's a normal agricultural
vehicle tearing a horse box
for a hunt or tractor coming out or
something of that nature which as we've
heard there are the various
um sewerages and other removal of muck
and stuff from the horses
but it is a very rare occasion i think
just
overkill in a country um side
locality of a super little hamlet
thank you thank you very much council
fielding
okay uh do we have any questions for our
ward member please
you can indicate in the chat if you do
i'll just give you a few steps to do
that
again i'm seeing very little movement
from our uh members of the committee so
i'm going to assume that scenario so um
uh caster fielding thank you very much
for your contribution you can of course
continue to watch from where you are
currently
placed okay let's move to let's move to
our um questions and points of
clarification to our offices has anyone
got any
points of clarification that they would
like to ask again if you can indicate in
the chat if you
do council parry first
thank you chair um maybe i'm being
just a little bit maybe it's the at the
end of a long day but i am just trying
to
wrestle with why
um we have an application in front of us
that has got an existing track access
that has been used that
that now requires planning permission
i appreciate it's had a new surface
which
as the officer's report highlights
um is is perfectly in accordance that
the
conservation officer doesn't have a
problem i'm just i'm just trying to
understand why
a track that has been used as an access
track
for many years um requires planning
permission and i just wonder whether the
officer could explain that for me
maybe i've missed something and i'm just
i just can't
i think it's late in the day
i i think i understand the question it's
fundamentally
it's required it's not permitted
development the lane of the truck is you
saw on the
agent's photos it was a field so they've
laid a hard service track that extends
all the way down to the stables
and therefore is required it's it's
development so therefore they need
planning permission for that
laying of that track the hard service
but it has it has been used as access
before
it has been used as a field access
before yes but as i said with the lane
of the access track itself
you still need planning permission and
then if we're going into the highways
objection
their opinion is lying in that access
track and new
which will take it away from the other
access that's there and go into the
stables that was permitted were now
intensified
use and therefore that's where their
objection then
comes from but in all of a regard it
does need planning permission
okay okay thank you very much for
flaming please
right um this is on the the highways
issue where the tail of the lord hanging
into the
when they pull into the closed gateway
i'm fairly confident that i heard the
the agents say that they're going to fit
an electric gate
um this might be relevant it might be
irrelevant where i keep my horses
we can phone the gate when we're about
100 yards away and it's open by the time
we get there
so if they're going to uh if they're
gonna have an electric gate
can we condition that they have
something where they can remotely access
that gate and have it open by the time
they turn up
um i don't think it's
much of an issue conditioning the gate
in itself because i guess you could do
it through a condition requiring details
the gates should be submitted
the question i would have and maybe
alice would be better suited to answer
this
is that i don't see how we could have
forced them to
phone up a hundred yards down the road
and there that's the
issue is making sure that it's still a
satisfactory gate
for the area um
i think that would be my major concern
with uh as i don't i
just wouldn't be enforceable in my
opinion
and we would need to have highways
confirmation that they're satisfied
before we can do anything yeah i i
wouldn't be confident
doing all that because like i said if
you're changing the gate it might
require a new sort of pillar and post
that could change the world and
the access and so forth um it's not
really the application that's before us
to be honest
yeah i think i think i agree with you
there okay no problem uh council
jennings i think he has a question for
you as well
yeah i just wanted some clarification on
implications
against going against highway decisions
i think to be honest ross or alice might
be better suited to answer that question
yep so um through you chairman um
the issue with this is obviously there
is an existing access there so it is
slightly different as councillor
parry picked up we're not going in a
situation where we don't have any access
the access is permitted just through
that's a time
what we're looking at here is the hard
standing which highway is considered to
lead to an
intensification and the issue with the
proximity of the gate
so the mppf is quite clear in that it
states that paragraph 109 that
development should only be prevented or
refused on highways grounds
if there would be an unacceptable impact
on highway safety or the residual commun
cumulative impact on the road network
would be severe so
if members don't consider that that bar
has been reached
um then you could be in a position where
where you can go toward an approval
we obviously have got the highway
engineer which is the technical
consulting saying that he does consider
that to be
highway harm so i do think um
you're potentially in sort of dangerous
territory
um but absolutely that's that's for
members to sort of weigh up in their
consideration of the application i'm not
sure ross whether you have anything to
add or whether that covers everything
um i think i'll just add that you're
obviously not bound by highways advice
but they are the acknowledged experts
and if you're going against it it needs
to be for sort of strong
cogent reasons but you're not um
you're not bound by their
recommendations
so can i have a follow-up question to
that please you
so okay we take a scenario where
they pull up in uh their horse with we
grant
we got we grant this application
they turn up with a horse trailer um
the arse of it's sticking out into the
road someone drives into it
and they turn around and say well who
are we gonna sue
are we liable because we've gone against
highway's decision on that
right i don't think so
okay like i say you need to have um
justifiable reasons to go against
highways advice but if you
you know if you feel you have then
you know that's that's fine
thank you i will err on the side of
caution i don't think i want to test
who's
liable and who's not um councillor parry
has another question please
thank you chairman it was just really um
picking up on
councillor jennings point and really a
question
to officers that if we were minded to go
against
highways um the highways um
objection uh and go for grant
would would surely the the
the impact on the character the area
wouldn't be damaged
by vehicles going all over the over the
verges so in fact it would actually
enhance
the um character and immunity
of this particular area because it would
not not destroy and i just wondered
whether going down that route might
carry any weight
so do you mean it's sorry i'll just try
and clarify so
you're referring to if we went against
highways
because it it's more important to
preserve the character of the
conservation area and say
yeah correct it's certainly a material
planning consideration
if as alice has pointed out if you don't
think the intensification the use
is so beyond what the mppf states
um you could go against highways
authority saying that it will protect
that area and there isn't such an
intensification of use
um if i'm correcting what i'm thinking
alyssa ross might point me wrong in that
but
that's how i think it could be done yeah
i mean i agree and that
the impact on the village green is
certainly a benefit of the proposal and
that's
established in the principle section of
joe's report
and so i completely agree with that i
think absolutely as joe's picked up
the argument i think that members are
more going down is in terms of the
intensification and the use of the
access so obviously you've picked up
that it is an existing access
county highways consider that laying the
hard standing is an intensification in
the use of the access
but the applicants confirmed that it is
a domestic stable
there's no intentions for it to be
commercial and we know that if it were
the intentional they did ultimately do
that they would need planning permission
again for
that use and again we could consider the
impact of of that level of traffic on
the access
so i think it's more sort of going down
there that there's no intensification in
the use that
is i think where you're kind of you'll
kind of
getting at there
okay uh very good and there are
no further questions for points to
clarification so let's move into
debate who would like to kick us off
uh councillor dixon first please and
then council jennings so cancer dixon
please
thank you chairman um looking at the
report
there's an assessment there that the new
axis
could cause severe detriment to the
safety of users of the public highway
i totally disagree essentially we've
seen
the slides of the good visibility
each way when any vehicle is moving out
from that gateway we've seen that that
gateway is
inside of drivers and vehicles from
a long distance off of anything slowly
turning into that gateway i think
highways have just plain got it wrong
and i think it's a situation whereby
it's only before as this evening
because highways have objected when it
comes to other planning reasons there's
no other reason to
refuse it i think highways are wrong
i would be in favor of granting this
application without any problem
whatsoever is that a proposal councillor
dixon
yes it is i would propose with granted
not available
forever uh my wife was
um cutting horses around um
my only interest in horses was with a
bit of garlic and french fries but
so i have nothing to do with i have
nothing to do with horses i'm not biased
but every time she used to pull into the
drive um
it wasn't deep enough so you should
leave the horse trailer in the middle of
the road
and there it was it was a road hazard
the simplest solution here would be take
out the fence
put some fencing about 10 meters down
and move the fence
the wooden fence back and it's no one's
it's job done there's no road there's no
hazards there's no problems
there seems to be something which is
sort of
preventing this i'm not quite sure if
it's just people have fallen out or
a bit of obstinacy i don't know but it's
a very simple solution to this
um and and we could overcome it quite
easily so
i'm i'm
not going to go against the
officer's decision on this and not and
i'll be
and i'm more in favor of of refusing it
is that a proposal counselor jennings no
not yet
okay cancer item next please thanks
chairman um i'd like to
uh second councillor dixon's uh proposal
to go against the officer's
recommendations
um okay uh okay no problem at all uh
thank you
uh councilman mills i can see you've
requested a second but that's been done
so do you have anything else to add
yes mr chairman i i know this um
i was old very well um
the visibility is good along there and
you you cannot tear it on that road
believe me
you you cannot you can't drive um
the fact that it's not being used
constantly
you know 24 7. i i
i've been very hard to uh go against i'm
sorry very hard to refuse this mr
chairman
uh it's
you'd be very very difficult to um
yeah up mr chairman all i can say is i
will
uh support the uh uh recognition the
grant thank you
okay thank you very much councillor
mills um i've seen anyone else wishing
to speak so i'll put my coupon's worth
in right now
um i agree with councillor jennings
and will propose that we refuse in line
with the officer's recommendation
um that is not a refusal on principal
grounds i have no issue with the
principle and clearly the officer has no
issue with the principle but i do have
con deep concern that we are overlooking
an objection from the iowa's authority
um councillor jennings talks of
setting gates back putting wooden fences
up etc
that has been proposed by the highways
authority
in their objection you can see that on
page 29 but it's not been what's been
put in front of us
if it were i think the highways would
remove their objection and we'll be
having a
very different conversation um i'd also
bring your attention to
a comment that counselor feeling made
during his uh
his little bit um uh talks about the
road being a single track and even if a
car comes the other way you have to go
on to the verge in order no it's
not a single track if that is the case
if we've got an overhanging lorry
sticking out of an entrance way
there's no way that to in my opinion
there's no way that two cars can
uh can pass behind it if there is a
conflict so
on highway grounds alone i cannot um
support this application i'd love to
if we didn't have a highways objection
but we do
um so i propose that we refuse in line
with the officer's recommendation
however we do have a proposal uh that
has been seconded
to grant councillor dixon before we move
to
a vote we do need to get conditions um
we also need to confirm
your uh reasoning for going against the
refusal that has been presented and
against the highways authority
if you could articulate that for us now
that would be great
quite simply i think the highways
authority have got it wrong
essentially you have a situation whereby
they have their opinions we are entitled
to
ours and we've seen the slides we've
seen the presentation
etc we've heard from the parish council
etc we can quite simply say that the
highways
we disagree with their analysis
perfectly entitled to do that
we're perfectly entitled to but i do
believe we need policy to support our
reasoning for that
and i'm not hearing any just you we
think you've got it wrong i don't think
is a sufficient legal case to
go against the officer's recommendation
i will seek clarification from our
solicitor to see what his view is on
that
well i think we should say why they've
got it wrong
thank you there isn't the
intensification
on that road there isn't the volume of
traffic on that road there's nothing to
indicate that there is
essentially we have a situation whereby
you've got good visibility
you can see where you are if there is a
lorry
on its way into that yard and it is
slightly
over the overhanging the road what would
cars do
try to go around it try to pass it or
would they simply wait
two minutes while it pulled in through
the gateway
which is exactly what you do in the
rural environment where
most of us live ross are you satisfied
that that is a
sufficient reason to go against the
highways objection
uh yes i'm unsatisfied with that and i'm
sure
that planning officers could assist with
them identifying with specific policies
but i'm
satisfied that council dixon has said
why he thinks the highways authority
have got it wrong
marvelous thank you very much council
adam are you happy with what's been put
forward
you can accept that stuff yes i'm happy
to second that and i mean
from from my point of view in in
seconding that i mean the
uh i think the the contribution by
highways was hyperbolic to say the least
and that actually one of the slides i
saw from i think
the parish council might be in the
applicant uh did demonstrate that there
was a route past the end of the lorry
so um i think that was justification and
as uh submitted evidence
um on their behalf okay um
thank you very much um i have had uh
a couple of counselors uh wish to speak
again before
we do that forgive me counselors before
we go into that i do want to just
uh finish mopping up what we're doing
now so we've had our proposal a second
day we've been given reasons
um i just want to get our planning
officers confirmation of any specific
policies
that you want to put in uh to the
reasoning for going against
uh the recommendation and any conditions
that you might want to
put in please from my perspective i
think the best way would do it would be
through the framework and say that there
isn't an intensification the use our
state of significant intensification use
that statewide framework
and therefore it isn't contrary to cs26
so the core strategy
i don't know if alice wanted to add
anything on top of that
no nothing to add on reasons joe i think
you picked up that quite
well if members are agreeable so then
it's just over to conditions which i
understand you have joe
yeah conditions wise to be honest
because it's retrospective we're happy
with the setting and so forth
it would just be the plans uh one
condition
okay lovely thank you very much um okay
so counselor kendall you would like to
speak so please
come in now if you would yeah thank you
chen
um i i'm forgetting whether it was
council jennings or yourself has said it
uh i think really
my concern here is purely safety we've
there is clearly room for an option
here that would satisfy absolute safety
um
in terms of maybe and i know we're
committed we're considering the
application before us but there is an
option
that you just move the gate back two or
three meters
and i just can't see why that isn't a
much more sensible option
i completely take counselor dixon's
point that you know there is a measure
of
common sense it's a large open space and
there is visibility but
if we even have the smallest doubt
in terms of safety and there is quite
clearly another option which is moving
the gate back
why don't we just go for it i mean that
would have support from highways
it would achieve a sensible um
conclusion i just don't know why we
wouldn't go with that
and it's in my mind incredibly simple to
do
so while i can i have a sympathy for
counselor dixon the world member of set
and for the applicant
i would err on the side of caution and
go with complete sensitiveness so
counselor richard chairman you said you
made a proposal i'll second your
proposal
i had to refuse that but i realized
we've got to get there first so
that's absolutely yeah marvelous thank
you very much cancer kendall
um cancer mills i see you've indicated a
wish to speak again do you still
speak no it's okay mr chairman thank you
marvelous
okay in that case we will move to a vote
um so the
in the first instance we have a proposal
from cancer dixon supported by council
adam
to grant the application uh for the
reasons we've already gone through
um i will go first council richards
against
thank you councillor fleming council
fleming for
councillor adam councillor adam four
councillor kendall councillor kendall
against
councillor crump councillor crump
against
queue councillor dixon councillor dixon
4. thank you councillor eden
council redden against thank you
councillor jennings
councillor jennings against councillor
mills
council mills for
regrettably okay one two three that's
four
four one two three six six against
okay in that case that proposal fails so
we
need to move to the second proposal
which was to refuse in line with the
officer's recommendation made by myself
and supported by councillor kendall
i will go first councillor richards four
thank you councillor fleming council
family against
councillor adam councillor adam again
councillor kendall kennedy councillor
kendall four
jennings castle jennings paul
councillor mills council mills against
councillor parry councillor parry four
thank you very much in that case
committee resolves to refuse application
twenty one zero zero
two two five ful at ascot house oscar in
banbury
there being no urgent biz or in fact
that sorry forgive me there is urgent
business and that um i need to inform
you that as of five o'clock this evening
um
uh we have heard that this will be our
last virtual meeting
for the foreseeable so the meeting that
was arranged for the 12th of may
has been postponed and we will be
resuming in-person meetings from the
26th
of may so for members of the public
watching and for our members on the
screen
um please do make a note of that and
members i'm looking forward to seeing
you all in person at the end of may
and there being no other urgent business
it really leaves me to thank everyone
involved so
our officers our members and indeed the
public that have participated tonight
thank you very much and we will see you
next time cheers
thanks mr chairman well done thank you
chairman
thank you